hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to dystopic celeea now this
game I found on gamejolt it's actually
very highly rated it's about a dystopian
future where everybody is working to
obey the overlords who employ them
really says my guess I have no idea we
all live under one simple rule do your
job if you fail to obey the rule you
will hear from management that's the
last thing you'll ever hear
I am IDNR to to employ it life
incorporated I'm a software security
technician and I hate my job done ah who
knows what will happen next in the life
of what an ID number 2 - oh no I've
overslept again damn what am I ever
going to do if I Drive fast enough I
might make it to the car ok oh ok WASD
hello computer that seems very happy to
see me
what did you and I do last night ok
anyway apparently I live up with in a
room where I have a - ladder always time
for a quick snack that was probably a
mistake tastes like the color gray also
tastes like people for some reason let's
do this let's get to work cuz I'm in
such a good mood work eat sleep work eat
sleep work eat sleep work don't you love
my fire barrel lon very dystopian I must
admit also why am I going to work oh
wait is it early morning it seems like
late at night I do like the music it's
very nice hello late again ID to - no I
was just carry on you're gonna be fired
and talk to management my Fink that's
not the name of the company the
revolution is here whose revolution
that's what I want to know hello fellow
employees in a dark poorly lit office
I'm just gonna go start a revolution
don't mind me oh oh wait a minute what
happens if I go talk to management ok
never mind that I will I'll save that
for later here I'm gonna do my job
apparently I do that real good
am I supposed okay
management wants you downstairs
management they know about me take the
elevator down to level D can I just
explain carry on
okay thanks boss you waddle away I'll
just make my way down to level D I'm
assuming the D stands for delightful
dandelions and not death elevator those
weird now there was a security military
patrol ah level D oh it's gonna damn it
who left these boxes here I have no idea
how to deal with them press J to jump
huh huh yeah okay this is too much
Oh press K to kick then yeah well wow if
I known I could kick boxes in the little
itty-bitty bits I wouldn't have worried
about too much more hello
management you requested me am I getting
a promotion oh hey hello employment bot
are you you got to press the button
until new orders ID to to press the
button is that all Gary on this is about
me being late you have five seconds to
comply that's new well I better go press
a button then huh okay I probably would
have died if I would have waited for
that
I better not screw this up oh oh you
want me to press a button a Oh like I'm
scared of your countdown what's gonna
happen to me if I don't huh get my arms
in the air like you just don't care
what's gonna happen I can wait it out
I'm a patient guy apply have to start
the game all over again but screw you
anyway I don't care what you say to me
bring on your screws oh god oh oh look
an Alan do 100 no this doesn't sound
right no it kind of doesn't Oh God
ah did I do that
and why did that happen I better report
back report back to who and what why why
what what happened
who is that button for hey boss till
noon you stupid idiot
do you know what you have done I don't
know I was just about to you had one
simple task if it gets out we're done
for you're lucky none of the containers
were damaged oh look here comes the
damage oh [ __ ]
Wow alright then good bye I'm out of
here
okay whoa hey how's it going there what
the hell's happening
oh well that don't look good
oh I almost made it the elevators right
there
ah come on oh okay
we were lucky to find you in time we are
in the sewers underneath the main
structure there isn't much time get
yourself to the surface we will be in
touch if you make it out alive okay
thanks I guess for saving me
alrighty then my guy with a mullet or a
girl
I can't quite tell part Zell and it's
like five pixels also where did the
sudden puzzle-platformer come in why are
the sewers tainted with acid okay am I
supposed to kick those I highly doubt Oh
maybe I am stay let no one is to leave
or enter Zone D why is everything
labeled D rules are that what about it
in character eye contact initiate
protocol 84 understood or less - I bind
objects Oh what so scared so
I didn't know how it's supposed to hide
behind it like that I thought you just
meant like hide behind it okay cool
oh hey how's it going glad you could
make it ID 22 you will need this to
defend yourself from the security a gun
why is happening what is protocol 84
protocol 80 force management's last
option to maintain power we will tell
you the rest at the rendezvous point
your own farm outside the city we ought
to meet you there good luck ok bye
thanks for wanting off yeah I've already
missed my bed and work Chris oh [ __ ]
Who am I gonna have to shoot alright I
got a gun alright I heal myself up good
thing I got that meal this my way well
that was a thing cool thanks for that
blah blah blah blah blah whoa blah blah
floki ow ow that really hurt
okay got his ammo that's good I guess
alrighty then I have no idea what's
going on here I walk just [ __ ] my legs
okey-dokey then
it's not going well for me Oh
blabla oh god I'm not good why is my
body jumping when I die hey on a second
yeah blah blah hey hey oh god it hurts
so much
alright yeah bababa
whoa hey okay I got him that time let's
try not to fall off and die that would
be a poor option whoop yeah [ __ ] out
okay so far so good
apparently I need to obey because Oh
bang would be the good thing to do
alrighty then
oh hey wait whoa hey god damn it
ok ha ha come on my body jumping this is
hard it's actually really difficult I
gotta watch my ammo consumption that
guy's dead you know I don't need to kill
him do I [ __ ] come on damn it this is
difficult
okay here we go here we go
got it got it whoa we got him back at
that obey obey obey whoa oh not that way
there we go okay this is actually really
really finicky so I gotta be very
careful
it was it I don't think there was
anything out there that I needed all
right okay all right come on
Jesus man this is actually challenging
sometimes I wonder why we keep doing
this was there to wonder it's your job
have you never thought about doing
something else like art or poetry I
trust the man in me has a plan for all
of us did you hear that you would
nothing oh hey all right then
back it's already spreading HQ
requesting back-up okay I don't know
what that was supposed to be I can't
take that guy's ammo or something what
the hell is going on here that's really
Hey whoa
oh I'm about to run out ammo
see dead
did I get him wow that's like the last
of every bit of my weight
what are you whoa okay that was weird
why was that a thing good boy whoa whoa
wait whoa wait whoa what cut damn it
okay this is not helping you fire that
oh hey and away we go
Wow
it's a horrible alien monster tubby this
guy ended like that I was into it man it
was interested man oh I knew it said
chapter 1 the beginning but I thought I
was gonna be a bit longer than that oh
man I was actually intrigued damn it
oh man I was like so into it ah man ah
come on
oh damn it man ok you can find the
development page for this game on the in
the description below but man I was
actually into it like what was the what
was it all about why was that all
happening I was really curious were you
guys curious to I I don't know why but
like cuz it doesn't matter to me if a
games picks later or not so long as it
plays well and the story's interesting
look it was really interesting and they
just cuts it off right there tell us but
to meet the guy who's without whatever I
so hopefully this cat this game gets
made another one of these because it was
actually really really interesting I
liked it very much I liked it a lot it
was fantastic for being short and really
simple and simplistic graphically was
but hey it's up to you for the final
judgement so let me know what you think
of this game down in the description
below should there be a second part I
think there should be I want to know
more thank you everybody so much for
watching check out the other cool indie
games that I played in the drift lower
and the annotations over there and as
always I will see
you in the next video be my Kenya back
in the head with a gallon of milk burger
glue normal dads go back here it sticks
you my body
you